mais ce gilles lurton merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre des
affaires sociales
alors que nous venons de commencer
l'examen du projet de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale pour 2016
les associations de personnes
handicapées et de parents d'enfants
handicapés manifestent leur désarroi
nous avons tous été saisis dans nos
circonscriptions de ces situations
enfants en attente de place en institut
médico éducatif jeunes adultes maintenu
dans ses établissements au titre de l'
amendement crée ton adulte nécessitant
des places médicalisées en attente de
place dans un foyer ou dans un
établissement spécialisé d'aidé par le
travail
autant de situations douloureuses autant
de personnes maintenues à domicile et
perdant ainsi tout espoir d'intégration
madame la ministre il nous faut entendre
leurs appels
beaucoup d'entre eux sont aujourd'hui
contraints de s'exiler dans des
établissements de belgique au risque
d'une rupture familiale d'un véritable
déracinement d'une perte de relations
avec leurs parents avec souvent un
sentiment d'abandon pour les parents qui
doivent placer leurs enfants loin de
chez eux
vous venez d'annoncer une somme de 15
millions d'euros pour faire face à cette
situation un premier pas certes mais
nettement insuffisant pour répondre aux
milliers de personnes handicapées qui
restent sans solution d'accueil
nettement insuffisant aussi quand nous
les comparons aux 4000 emplois financés
par notre pays sur le territoire belge
un coût d'au moins 250 millions d'euros
par an pour nos budgets sociaux et pour
les conseils départementaux un montant
financier qu'il nous faut ramener dans
notre pays une telle situation doit nous
mobiliser au delà de nos appartenances
politiques
alors madame la ministre quelles mesures
comptez vous prendre pour permettre à
toutes ces personnes handicapées de
trouver les places d'accueil dont elles
ont besoin dans notre pays
merci la parole est à madame la
secrétaire d'état chargé des personnes
handicapées et de la lutte contre
l'exclusion
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député vous avez raison
clairement clairement la situation de
ces familles forcé de s'exiler en
belgique est inacceptable elle est
douloureuse mais elle est aussi
inacceptable et je veux le dire très
clairement devant vous aujourd'hui les
départs forcés pour la belgique pour les
personnes handicapées financé par
l'assurance maladie
à partir de maintenant c'est fini pour
vous répondre
complètement il faut que je vous donne
la réalité de la situation aujourd'hui
la réalité de la situation c'est qu'il y
a des milliers de personnes handicapées
qui s'exilent en belgique pour être
accueillis dans des établissements
depuis plus de dix ans malgré la
création de 4000 nouvelles à ses parents
en france malgré la réalité du nombre de
places en france c'est-à-dire 490 mille
places malgré les 9 milliards d'euros
qui sont chaque année investie par
l'assurance maladie pour ces places et
bien ce nombre ne baisse pas c'est la
raison pour laquelle comme ce nombre ne
baisse pas nous avons avec marisol
touraine adopté une stratégie spécifique
justement pour lutter contre ces départs
forcés en belgique alors cette stratégie
quelle est elle ça a démarré sa a débuté
il ya un peu plus d'un an avec l'accord
entre la france et la wallonie
premier objectif au moins établir la
qualité de l'accueil en belgique quand
malheureusement les gens ont dû partir
en belgique c'est fait avec cet accord
entre la france et la wallonie
deuxième étape de cette stratégie
c'est ce que nous avons annoncé avec
marisol touraine il y a quinze jours
c'est à dire nous stoppons le flux de
l'assurance maladie vers la belgique il
n'y aura plus de finances qui partiront
partiront vers la belgique à partir de
l'assurance maladie est un fonds
d'amorçage a été mis en place de 15
millions d'euros qui est uniquement un
fonds d'amorçage pour permettre la
création de places sur mesure à
proximité des domiciles des personnes ce
que j'attends maintenant ce que
j'attends maintenant c'est que les
conseils départementaux suivent
l'exemple de l'assurance maladie
parce que eux aussi eu aussi oriente
vers la belgique et il est donc
souhaitable et beaucoup d'entre eux sont
déjà engagés il est regrettable que les
conseils départementaux s'engage à côté
du gouvernement
merci la parole est à mme e